et on a entendu beaucoup de choses vous
savez sur le dossier de l'aluminium
avoir parlé avec la professeure
geneviève dufour de l'université de
sherbrooke spécialisé en droit
international économique bonjour madame
dufour toujours première question toute
simple est ce que les américains ont
raison de dire que le canada envoie trop
d'aluminium vers les états unis
mais c'est certain qu'on en voit
beaucoup d'aluminium aux états unis 85 %
notre production va aux états unis mais
ils le savent et ils le veulent ils ne
produisent plus ou à peu près plus
d'aluminium primaire aux états unis pour
plein de raisons sur lesquelles on
pourra revenir mais ils ont besoin de
notre aluminium primaire pour pouvoir
ensuite l'utiliser comme un train dans
ce qu'ils vont fabriquer est ce qu on en
voit trop c'est la question et c'est ça
et c'est une question juridique en fait
on se rappelle que bon il ya deux ans
les états unis où l'administration de
monsieur jobs a menacé d'imposer des
taxes douanières sur la ligne homme
émacié il le fait et tout s'est conclu
par une entente en mai 2019 et dans
cette entente là clairement il est écrit
que dont les pays vont se retenir
d'inonder l'autre pays d'aluminium mais
que et c'est ça qui est important
s'il ya une forte augmentation subite de
l'aluminium dans un pays le pays
importateurs s'il considère que cette
forte augmentation subite et sur une
longue période
il peut entamer des discussions d'une
période de consultation avec le pays
exportateurs donc dans ce qu'austin un
mur oui tout à fait une période de
discussions de négociations pour que le
pays exportateurs en l'occurrence le
canada steens clic pour que le canada
reçoivent les arguments des états unis
parce que tout se sait dans le cadre de
la section de 32 sur la défense de
sécurité nationale donc c'est important
quand même que les américains puissent
préserver leur sécurité nationale
mais c'est aussi important que le canada
puisse défendre son point de vue
s'explique et ils s'ajustent et le cas
échéant
et donc c'était prévu dans cette entente
là qu'un pays pouvait imposer
suite
consultation des surtaxes douanière de
10% sur l'aluminium mais et s'il est
important et c'est très très clair et
pour une juriste c'est très important et
christine une forte augmentation subite
des importations et ce pendant une
longue période
unia porical franchement des traceurs
hurla pardon il n'y a pas eu de fortes
augmentations selon vous il ya peut-être
une augmentation voilà où j'ai
l'impression que le bât blesse c'est que
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y avait une
forte augmentation sur la longue période
et on peut surtout pas utiliser les
derniers mois qu'un cadre de référence
on on est en pleine pandémie
les alumineries ont certes continué à
fonctionner maison fonctionner
différemment les entreprises utilisaient
ces intrus ont fermé pour la plupart en
série orientée
donc on peut pas utiliser cette période
si à mon avis pour mettre en place le
lait sur taïwan ya prévu dans l'entente
dès 2010 n'ont alors ses tarifs la roma
l'allée du tri ci est ce qu'ils feront
mal également aussi aux américains qui
consomment beaucoup de produits avec
l'aluminium et même l'endroit qui avait
été choisi par dans notre chambre je
pense à frapper tout le monde sait au
repos qui utilisent de l'aluminium
danseuse électroménager et c'est là
qu'on se rend compte que la suite
championnat comptera absolument pas le
jeu du commerce international il ne
comprend pas que lorsqu'il annonce
humour qui va y avoir une sorte de la
dernière de 10 % sur tous les produits
d'aluminium est portée aux états unis ce
sont les américains qui en définitive
vont payer ce surplus de taxes là
walpole à chaque fois qu'il va vouloir
acheter l'aluminium va pouvoir il va
devoir payer 10% plus et donc les
américains vont devoir payer 10% de plus
lorsqu'ils vont acheter ces produits là
et malheureusement les canadiens aussi
parce qu'on a une industrie extrêmement
intégrer regardons la légalité de la
chose vêtement est ce que les américains
peuvent finalement donc tarifs et
l'aluminium et ce qui est pas une
protection là dedans dans la série
ouais mais c'est aussi ça le principe
sic non ils peuvent pas imposer des
surtaxes joignable mais là où les
américains jouent c'est sur une
exception l'exception de défense de
sécurité nationale
et donc s'ils sont capables de démontrer
que c'est pour protéger leur sécurité
nationale
il ya pas de problème il n'y a pas
d'enjeu or c'est une exception la
défense de sécurité nationale qui a été
très très peu interprété par les juges
par exemple de l'organisation mondiale
du commerce ou d'autres organes de
règlement des différends il le souligner
qui est en jeu ici au jamais été
interprétée
on avait poursuivi les américains devant
tribunal de l'om sait il ya douze ans
mais suite à l'entente de mai 2009 on a
annulé notre plainte devant wayne site
pour s'adjuger la séoune probablement
oui on pourrait mais on a une entente
eastick est encore plus précise que
l'accord de libre échange entre le
canada les états-unis l'excès et c'est
l'entente de mai 2009 qui prévoit que
les américains ont le droit d'imposer
des surfaces douanière de 10%
si on fait une consultation avec le
canada et style répondre la condition
d'une forte augmentation subite des
importations sur une longue période fait
en 30 secondes la stratégie canadienne
juin et pour oeil dent pour dent parce
que l'on l'annoncé aujourd'hui on va
sanctionner des produits américains est
ce que c'est ce qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
stratégie selon vous en tout cas c'est
la stratégie à adopter et c'est la
stratégie qui est prévu aussi dans
l'entente de mai 2010 la fille est prévu
que le canada a le droit d'adopter des
mesures de rétorsion sur les produits de
l'aluminium et sur les produits
contenant de la lumière ce que le canada
fait le canada est tout à fait légal
on va en parler et j'imagine lors des
prochaines semaines geneviève dufour
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
te plaisait